what a news day uh so much happening so
much going on so much to talk about glad
you're joining me I'm going to wait just
a couple of minutes to allow people to
get connected to the stream etc etc but
we are going to be talking about the
Sally eights hearing of today we are
going to be talking about the recent and
I don't think that these are unrelated
we're also going to be talking about the
revelation that President Barack Obama
specifically specifically warned then
president-elect Trump not to hire
Michael Flynn major major warning there
a warning that it appears pretty clearly
that Donald Trump did not heed so
there's going to be a I believe that
there is going to be significant fallout
significant fallout from the hearing
today and we've been waiting to hear
from Sally Yates for some time and and
we finally did today and there was a lot
there you know i'm i hope the stream is
working okay i'm not able to see the
stream usually i monitor it but i'm not
able to see it can people hear me at all
let's start there is anybody even able
to hear me not sure about that hmm maybe
I should start over I'm not really sure
can anyone see people can hear me can
people see me that hmm you see and hear
me I can't see myself huh there seems to
be something up with the stream here
let's see if I can restart it's ten
all right trying this again let's see if
this works uh not sure what could be
causing the problem my stream is
receiving video and audio from my
computer I just don't know why people
weren't able to see me a lot of people
saying it's working fine interesting I
can't tell I genuinely can't tell
whether the stream is currently working
or not working um maybe just refresh
people saying it's all good getting the
same thing frozen piece some people just
hear me some people can see me I don't
really know hmm I can't see myself
that's for sure
it was bad now it's good people are
saying other people saying the screen is
frozen and I wish I was just comfortable
that this was actually working right now
no picture or audio refresh refresh 86
times refreshing it was fine mmm again
there's nothing I can fix on my end
there may be some kind of issue with
YouTube live right now because the
stream is sending video and it is all
working fine on my end all right I think
I'm going to continue on here because it
seems it's at least working for some
people and I don't believe that the
issue is on my end anyway
and beyond that I don't think that there
is much that I can do okay let's just
jump into it all right this is a live
stream if you have not watched a live
stream before we are really live unless
this is a replay if it says live now
then we're live it's about 6:30 4:00
p.m. Eastern Time on May 8th 2017 number
2 super chat is on please use super chat
not only is it a great way to send in
questions and comments which I will read
and answer if they are questions
reasonable questions ideally but it is
also a great way to support the program
also new members and patrons who sign up
or
pledge during the program we'll get live
shoutouts and thank-yous of course you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership you can also
make a pledge at patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show number 4 we do
have moderators if you are obviously
trolling or posting hateful messages in
the chat you are going to get blocked
banned muted call it whatever you want
subtle trolling will probably not get
you banned as long as it's subtle enough
that the moderators don't notice ok so I
I'm going to continue I know some people
are having trouble with the stream I
double-checked it's it's not on our end
I've got a strong wired connection
YouTube is receiving audio and video
from us perfectly fine so it appears
that there is something going on with
YouTube streaming and I'll keep going to
the extent that I can and if if you
refresh people are saying if you refresh
that that might work but again there's
really nothing on my end that it appears
as though I can do I've already
restarted the stream on my end and again
I'm getting perfect stream health and
everything seems to be working fine a
lot of people are saying that it's also
working fine one thing that seems to be
going on is it seems that it's chrome
users that are reporting trouble which
is weird usually chrome is what works
well but in this particular case people
reporting that chrome is is not working
and that Firefox is and you know what
the same thing is going on for me I just
went from Chrome to Firefox and the
Firefox version it's weird
seems to be working just fine and AD
played etc so in any case something very
very strange going on I plan to continue
and then we will see ultimately what
happens with the recorded version sali
aids testimony big story lines from the
Sally Yates testimony you know when you
watch six hours of testimony
sometimes it seems as though oh yeah
nothing's really happening it's just a
lot of talking I can't tell what's going
on some major revelations in the Sally
eights testimony Sally eighths of course
is the former acting Attorney General at
the end of the Obama administration and
for a few days under Donald Trump she
believed that the initial Trump travel
ban was unconstitutional something that
Donald Trump fired her for she finally
has testified and she tested here a few
of the big things that Sally Yates told
us today which tell us a lot about what
is going on with this Trump Russia
investigation number one Sally Yates
testified earlier today that the
Russians knew for some time that
disgraced national security adviser
former national security adviser Michael
Flynn had done concerning things and
that not only did Russia know about this
Russia had proof of this and thus would
have been able to blackmail to blackmail
a Michael Flynn potentially and this
becomes even bigger sort of in terms of
Donald Trump's liability for ignoring
President Barack Obama it becomes an
even bigger issue when we have now
learned on the same day by the way that
President Barack Obama advised Donald
Trump not to not to hire Michael Flynn
and let me pause it seems a lot of
people are still having trouble with the
stream so let me just try stopping it
altogether and restarting it and and
we'll see what we get
okay I think this is going to be the
last attempt this is the last thing I
can think of to do I've completely
restarted the stream different browser
restarted the streaming software it has
been a full and total restart if this
doesn't work I don't know what else I
could possibly do I don't believe it has
anything to do with adblock I don't
think it has anything to do with any of
those things there just seems to be
something going on right now with
YouTube's live stream and I don't know
what it could be and for people saying
David live stream and twitch
we don't have 400,000 subscribers on
Twitch so that that's not really that's
not really solution to what we're trying
to do here are people still having an
issue is it working now I'll be honest
on my end I'm trying to monitor my own
stream and it's not working but I don't
know I don't know what it is that's that
that's causing the issue it's very very
strange if this doesn't work there's
probably only one other thing I can try
and it would be it's not the ideal thing
it would be going to totally different
streaming software people saying still
not working spinning wheel it is working
alright on my end it's not working I'm
going to give this one more shot using
different sock okay I am now back with
totally different software completely
different software if this doesn't work
it can truly only mean that the issue is
somewhere on youtubes end and if this
this doesn't work I really don't know
what else we would be able to do there's
clearly some kind of problem normally we
would have you know several hundred or
even a thousand people on the stream at
this point and if this doesn't work then
I don't know what else I could possibly
do is this any better is anybody able to
see this it seems most people still are
not getting video and for people talking
about adblock
I don't have ad block and it's not
working for me so I don't I don't think
this has anything to do whatsoever with
that block anybody I'm still not seeing
video when I monitor the stream on the
public website so can't get it working
David didn't work I like how people
think I'm just incompetent there's one
button it's stream YouTube is receiving
the stream video if it's if it's not
working beyond that the problem goes
beyond anything on now on my computer
working videos finds some people can see
a lot of people still saying that it is
not working I genuinely don't know what
I do know is that 91 people on the
stream is not something that would
normally take place working video out of
sync Blanc yeah I think there is
genuinely something wrong right now with
what is going on as far as the video
goes people able to hear me clearly I've
got all the right stuff selected here
yeah people without adblock are having a
problem as well like a people act like
I'm clueless about streaming I have a
sense of what I'm doing with streaming
and unfortunately there seems to be
something major going on here is there
any way we can even find out if there is
some systemic problem with with YouTube
life going on right now and again people
saying it's an issue of the resolution
or whatever it's really not we've got a
very very fast internet connection here
and the the upload of the video to
YouTube is working completely fine it's
it's a it's a broader issue that we are
having here yeah I'm just not sure
there's one other thing I could try and
that is if I were to attempt to stream
from my phone yeah still not working
alright that's the last thing I'm going
to try give me give me